うっすらだな
でやっぱ、微妙に違うな
わかんない
あんまり～。でも日焼けしなかったね
こんにちは！はじめしゃちょーです。
思ったよりくっきり分かれてなかったっすね
うっすら違いがあるぐらいです
でな、まあ、昨日の撮影で僕は熱中症になったわけで
まだ体がしんどいんですけど、
みんな、夏は外出るとき気をつけろよ！
はい、というわけで今日はねぇ
のどが渇いてるわけなんでぇ
今回はこちら
えっと、「ソーダストリームジェネシスデラックススターターキットインクルーズ」
飲み物を炭酸にするようなやつなんすよ多分
熱中症でね、ちょっと冷たいものをこう、たくさんのみたいわけなんすよ
うぉ。ウェルカム。
あ、ソーダメーカーだ
これソーダーメーカーって言うんだ
『「あっ」という間に出来上がります。掃除の必要もありません。毎日低価格で炭酸飲料を。』
お～。お得。お得らしいです。
とりあえず、これがあれば炭酸飲料がすぐ作れるみたいな
あぶな、おも、重いよ！
え、ガチのもんじゃんこれ
あぶな
やばい、やばい
ｶﾞｽﾌﾞｪ、ガスボンベが入っています
えぇ、危ないなあ。
どすすすしぃよう　(どうしよう)
今日は実際にね、
この炭酸飲料をね、
この、このソーダメーカーを使って
色んな飲み物を炭酸飲料にしていこうと思っています。
でもな、そんなに上手くいくとは俺も思ってないんだよ
だから、な？
髪の毛伸びたなあ
というわけで今日は
うん、さて、とりあえずセッティング
スタート
これキャップはまだいいのか
こう刺します
これ違うわ
これをまず設置する
あ～、おっけおっけおっけ、きたきた
あぁ、こわ
あ～、きたきたきた
お～、これでいいの？
おし、これで多分大丈夫だ
なんかボタンみたいなのは無い物なんですかね
怖いよぉ
電源とか無い感じ？
うわ待って
アモ、スーっ(嗅ぐ音)
あ
もう来てる感じ？
もう二酸化炭素出てんじゃねこれ
じゃあさっそく、色んなものを炭酸にしていきましょう
カキ氷のシロップとかね
このまま入れるとただのカキ氷の味のする甘ったるいジュースになるんだが
なんとなんとのよ(？)
炭酸を入れると！
美味しい炭酸ジュースになるという話を聞きました
とりあえずね
カキ氷炭酸ジュースを作ろう
味は良くても色が…
うっあぁ
これをちょっと、たんちゃんたん炭酸にしてみましょう
僕は心配だよ。本当にできるか
ｿｰﾀﾞﾒｰｶｰ：しゅるじゅｒ
ぉえ
ｿｰﾀﾞｰﾒｰｶｰ：じゅるしゅｒ
おわ！
ｿｰﾀﾞﾒｰｶｰ：(炭酸にする音)
えぇ…
ｿｰﾀﾞﾒｰｶｰ：プスー
おい！
なにこれ！
ｿｰﾀﾞﾒｰｶｰ：プスー
わー！えっ待って怖い
爆発する！！
待って待って、大丈夫?大丈夫？
ｿｰﾀﾞﾒｰｶｰ：ジュルル
大丈夫なのこれ
ｿｰﾀﾞﾒｰｶｰ：じゅrrrr
ｿｰﾀﾞﾒｰｶｰ：プスー！
えぇ！？あ、これ、
こうするとなんかぷしゅーってなるんだ。
ｿｰﾀﾞﾒｰｶｰ：じゅrrrr
ｿｰﾀﾞﾒｰｶｰ：プスー！
うわ。うわ！でも炭酸っぽいぞ
炭酸感は出てます
え、これ本当にできたらすごいよ
飲んでみましょう
なるほどな
くいってやると炭酸が
ちゃんと導入されるんだ
飲んでみます。
あ
MONSTERだ！
え、あのなんか
あれの味になります。ほらあの
MONSTERとかレッドブルとかオロナミンCとかリポビタンDとか
なんかそういう栄養剤チックな味に変わりました。
こりゃびっくりだよ
炭酸って砂糖たくさん入ってるんだなぁ。多分
どんどんいってみよう
はい、じゃあ次は牛乳をやってみましょう
炭酸の牛乳なんて作った事もないし飲んだ事も無いんで
わりと興味本位感がありますね
よし、普通に飲めばおいしいんすよね牛乳
牛乳は好きなんだけど
こいつを炭酸にしたときにどういう味になるのかって言うのがね、
気になるよね
３，２，１　ファイヤー
ｿｰﾀﾞﾒｰｶｰ：炭酸にする音
え待ってなんか大丈夫か
え溢れる！
ちょ待った待った。たんま
ｿｰﾀﾞﾒｰｶｰ：プスー！
え待って待って待った
ｿｰﾀﾞﾒｰｶｰ：じゅう…
大丈夫？
これ、ひょっとして牛乳だめなのかな
ｿｰﾀﾞﾒｰｶｰ：炭酸にしている音
ｿｰﾀﾞﾒｰｶｰ：プスー！！！！
うおあー！！
まってどっから出て来てんのお前！
待って待って待って
何、逆流してるんだけど！！
ちょっと待って待ってｗ
なんでなんで！
もういいやでも作っちゃおう！
作りたいんだ俺は
ｿｰﾀﾞﾒｰｶｰ：炭酸にしている音
ｿｰﾀﾞﾒｰｶｰ：ブー！！！！
うわーー！！
ｿｰﾀﾞﾒｰｶｰ：プスゥゥゥゥゥゥ
まって絶対におかしいでしょ
待て待て待て待て待て待てって！！
ちょっと待って待てばかばか
おいまじかよ、大惨事じゃねえか…
うぅん
刺激的に
まずい
じゃあ次は普通にお茶
お茶の炭酸もね見たこと無いんでどこまでね
お茶の炭酸って言うのがね美味しいかどうか
今回明らかになります
ﾊｼﾞﾒ：おるぁあ！
よぉし
ｿｰﾀﾞﾒｰｶｰ：プスー
なんか…
いつもこぼれちゃうんだけど
お茶の炭酸です
ただのしょんべｎ
じゃあ早速飲んでみましょう！
こりゃねえわ
最後はちょっとね、
ここ(頭)をつかってね
新しい何かをやってみましょう
普通にコーラでございます
炭酸を抜かないようにいきましょう
俺がしたいのはあれだ
すでに炭酸が入っているものに
さらに炭酸を付け足すとどうなるか
炭酸×炭酸で
ひょっとしたらとんでもない事になるかもしんねえ
炭酸っつうのは、二酸化炭素が入っているわけだから
下手すると、四酸化たｎ
じゃあいってみましょう
え、爆発しないよね
爆発だけはいやだなあ
いきます
ｿｰﾀﾞﾒｰｶｰ：炭酸を足している音
ｿｰﾀﾞﾒｰｶｰ：ブービリ　ﾊｼﾞﾒ：うわあああ
大丈夫かな
え、こわい！！
まってまってちょ、やばい
ｿｰﾀﾞﾒｰｶｰ：プスー！
ちょっと弱まったぁ